- I just had to ask this one question
'cause you've done so many,
so many films that everybody,
I imagine anytime you get stopped,
it's always a different film
because there's so many
that are just, not just great,
maybe it just have such a great
impact on humanity overall.
Like, whether it was,
you know, a deeper thing
or a lighter thing,
or any way or any sort,
but I'm curious like, what
your favorite movie to do was.
I know that's probably gotta be hard
'cause people ask me questions,
but funny enough,
everybody always thinks
I love "The Bodyguard."
That is like, one of my
favorite movies of all time,
but that's not my favorite of yours,
and this says something about me
that my favorite, I think
it's called "Mr. Brooks,"
and you're a serial killer.
- Yeah.
- Okay, I love that one
because it was so out of pocket
and I thought that story was amazing,
how it did the twisting
- Yeah.
- At the end,
and I, it was just something
that was unpredictable
for me when I watched it,
but I was curious.
What's one of yours?
Like, what's one that sticks out
that like if it's on, you'll like, keep on
and not turn off?
- Well, I don't do that.
I don't fall in love with
myself on the screen.
You know--
- Not even
if it's been like, years?
Like, I mean like, years of watching--
- Sometimes, the kids would walk in
and they go, "Is that, that's you."
- Yeah.
- And it's like,
no, they won't let me turn it off
for a second and eventually,
I kinda have to walk out of the room.
What I know in my heart
is that when you make a movie,
there's a chance for it to live forever,
and it looks forever if it's fresh air,
if it challenges you,
if it makes you laugh,
if it makes you cry,
if it surprises you.
Movies have all those things going for it,
but what they have is
they also have the ability
to do something that
you'll never ever forget.
It's just hard, movies aren't easy.
So, it's hard to make a great one.
- I agree.